An appropriate response to nearly any rhetorical
playground question from “What’s up?”
to “Guess what?”, “chicken butt” has
been an important part of the childish lexicon
for many decades.
The retort’s origins are usually speculated
to have come from a practice common to street
merchants when they would call out what they
were offering and how much it cost.
One particularly delicious item was advertised
as:
Chicken butt!
Five cents a cut!
Butt, in this sense didn’t mean the back
end of the bird, but, rather, its shoulder.
A long time ago, butchers would pack less
desirable cuts, like shoulders, into barrels,
either to store them or ship them.
Barrels like these had been called butts since
the late 14th century, after the Modern French
word for a barrel or wineskin, botte and the
Latin buttis (for cask).
Over time, the term was applied to the cuts
of meat within the barrels as well.
It’s hard to verify when a chicken shoulder
cost $0.05, although historical data on the
cost of a whole chicken is relatively easy
to find.
For instance, during the Roaring Twenties,
hens were sold for between $0.36 and $0.38
per pound (about $4.43 today), but at the
height of the Great Depression, the price
of a hen had dropped to just $0.21 per pound
(about $3 today).
One theory as to why the expression became
so popular is tied to the 1930s.
In 1935, George Gershwin’s Porgy and Bess
debuted, and in it, Maria compares Sporting
Life to a chicken, invoking the merchants’
chant:
I hates yo’ struttin’ style,
Yes sir, and yo’ god d*mn silly smile
an yo’ ten cent di’mons an’ yo’ fi’
cent butts.
Oh, I hates yo’ guts.
All that said, as far as I can find, there
is no documented evidence of anything to the
effect of “What’s up?” or “Guess what?”
(or any of the many variants) followed by
“Chicken Butt!” until Mississippian Charles
G. Bell’s 1962 novel The Married Land.
In it, we find:
…but what as a boy he had spoken with boys,
white and colored, when they ran and fought
together (“What, what, chicken butt, come
around the house and lick it up.)
Disregarding a rather interesting, though
seemingly unrelated, 1970 work Psychoanalytic
Study of the Child – Volume 25 in which
one Ruth S. Eissler describes a girl named
Naomi who uses some peculiar terms such as
“chicken-butt” to mean “sex” and “cookie”
to mean “vagina” and is described as “confusingly
using words that she senses are somehow inaccurate…”,
next up in the known documented instances
of this phrase we have a rather telling instance
appearing in the 1973 book Black Language
by Malachi Andrews and Paul T. Owens.
On page 73 it contains the following entry:
Chicken Butt- When someone calls out, “What?”,
because they didn’t hear, a reply might
be the rhyme, “Chicken Butt.”
It means forget it; I am not going to repeat
it.
Junior flip usage.
In that same year, it was noted in the National
Education Association of the United States’
Today’s Education Volumes 62-64 that at
least some children were using “chicken
butt” as a slang insult: “‘Mrs. Pratt,
come check me off.’
If I paid no attention and helped somebody
else, he might yell again, ‘Mrs. Pratt!’
If I still paid no attention, he might mutter
something about my being a ‘chicken butt.'”
Following that up, the next documented instance
I could find of the general phrase in question
was in the 1983 work The Black Nation.
In Volumes 3-5 of that work, the following
appears:
…chicken cacciatore, chicken-alla-wendy,
chicken — alla-king ir poor folks eat chicken
feet, chicken necks chicken gizzards, chickenstew
(with no chicken) chicken backs SAY WHAT!?
CHICKEN BUTT!!!!!!!!!!! don’t you wish that
all rich folks would turn into a plucked chicken
& fly into a vat of hot grease & let us poor
folks eat good for a while…
So, from the documented evidence (and quite
a bit of somewhat less reliable personal anecdotes),
it would seem as if, whether actually connected
to any early 20th century merchant slang or
not, the phrase and its variants originated
in southern black-American culture at least
as early as the 1960s and probably a bit before.
However, if the documented evidence is any
indication, this phrase didn’t catch on
among a wider audience until sometime in the
late 1970s and 1980s, at which point it soon
became a somewhat ubiquitous expression among
all American youth, along with variants like
“Guess what?” and rhyming offshoots like
“Guess why?
Chicken thigh!” and “Guess who?
Chicken tattoo!”
Several years ago, an undercover video surfaced
showing egg hatchery workers glibly tossing
baby chicks into a grinder alive.
An accepted industry practice called “instantaneous
euthanasia,” it accounts for the slaughter
of 200,000,000 male chicks each year (the
males were culled because they couldn’t
produce eggs and supposedly would be prohibitively
expensive to raise as meat chickens).
While acknowledging the situation wasn’t
ideal, a spokesman for The United Egg Producers,
Mitch Head, noted, “There is, unfortunately,
no way to breed eggs that only produce female
hens.
If someone has a need for 200 million male
chicks, we’re happy to provide them to anyone
who wants them.
But we can find no market, no need.”
He also noted that, while seemingly brutal,
the use of the grinder “is the most instantaneous
way to euthanize chicks.”
However, things are looking up for male chicks…
kind of.
Technology has advanced so that it is possible
to detect the sex of a chick early on while
it’s still in the egg.
Expected to be commercially viable within
four years, the egg producers industry group
has recently announced that by 2020, they
should be able to end the practice of grinding
newborn baby chickens to death.
Instead, they’ll just sell the fertilized
eggs as, well, eggs.
So the question to you, dear readers, is this-
is it better to exist somewhat consciously
for an exceptionally short while only to have
your fate be to get snuffed out in a grinder
shortly after emerging from your shell, or
to never really exist at all on any conscious
level?